i wish it this pandemic hadn't gone down
or whatever we want to call it
you can take some positives out of it
there have been i
can wear the scarf without being judged
for the rest of my life i mean you were
judged when you walked in here but still
i can still
repeat like if i walked in another place
like get out of here now there's like
maybe sick all right matches whatever
yeah i mean i
just wear this i'm gonna wear this at
21. say that right now are you rocking
oh this just
this is my thing now dude welcome to
scarf city baby when you guys start
wearing one around your wrist oh my god
yeah
unless you play guitar you can't wear it
around the wrist
obviously don't do that forever and i
tell you so back when
you remember when those thick leather
cuffs oh yeah okay
so we had a thick level cut leather cuff
and i was playing baton rouge louisiana
and i walk into this club and uh the
guy's like all right and i've never been
there before he goes okay and we go over
the whole thing
and he said to me he goes but uh look
man um and what do you need for sound i
told him he goes what's the setup and i
told him
he goes listen we don't have a setup for
a bird and i go what
[Music]
and he goes he goes we we can't we i
mean your bird can't come i'm like
what are you talking about he goes isn't
that for a bird i'm like oh no
it's not it's not a bird
makes so much sense really like you have
the bird in there
can i tell you it was you gotta be a
special dude to rock him now we said it
before like with brad pitt you can wear
whatever you want well
this dude dude even look at the bracelet
it's like i'm sure maybe one of his kids
gave it to him but
if i just came into rock and i'd be like
dude come on man can you go back to what
the title this is called
johnny depp's style leather oh so he
doesn't
this isn't his that's not that's
probably gucci or some [ __ ] like that
i gotta tell you man i barely he looks
showered in that picture so i'm alarmed
by that yeah
this johnny depp looks like there you go
it's still good looking he looks dope
like that but he does cool he smells he
looks like he smells like old meat
yeah like he sounds like a pirate yeah
yeah yeah he's got a little
so this is bella thorne she was
a disney actress when she was a kid
she's now an adult
and she announced the other day that she
was gonna have an only fans account
and she crashed the site when she
launched they weren't ready for
they weren't ready for it uh her rates
start at
twenty dollars to sixty dollars and
they're estimating that she's gonna make
a million dollars a month
what what for naked pictures or just
you could post whatever you want on only
hold on before i react how old kat
22. okay so far
where was i yeah she's
ridiculous she's super hot
it's that's the time she has 23 million
followers
i think the appeal is also that she was
on disney but is she posting
nudes on this you could
it doesn't necessarily mean she is she
just says that she's launching an only
fans account and she already
posts up kind of risque photos of
herself so we don't know exactly what's
going to be on there
but you like my boy stevie blue eyes his
girlfriend's you know one of the biggest
porn stars in the world
who's his girlfriend um
something annis uh uh annis or amy
is that a nice way nicole anderson oh
anderson i think he said anna i'm like
we pronounce it you don't work nicole
anderson i don't she's a beast
in a good way but so but what's
interesting is he goes
you don't real like it's only fans has
changed the game for pono stars because
now there's no set there's no like they
don't have to pay anybody a fee
right they do only fans a bunch of times
a week and they're making
stupid money so that million dollars
doesn't surprise me at all because i
know how much some of these other girls
make because now they're just like
posting like
nicole's posting you know [ __ ] stevie
and it's just for only fans and then
they don't have to upload to you porn or
nothing they're making he's posting
[ __ ] stevie
you're stevie's a porno star opener is a
part of
porno star so now i'm gonna have to get
familiar with her work
you should because i'm gonna have to at
least look you know if he's a friend of
a friend i gotta look you gotta look
yeah i mean you gotta look
wait so stevie's packing heat
i mean not you know sun's heat but right
yeah yeah but okay
bigger than shaq listen i'm gonna
i just i can't believe it i can't
believe that it's something that big
well go to heat.com and you'll see
how much would it cost you so say i was
going to tell you listen
b you're going to make a million a month
on an only fans account but it's got to
be [ __ ] and ball shots
of like me jerking off no just whatever
only fans whatever they're doing
i don't know what all they do on yeah
i'm so if do they make requests
uh i don't know all right give us this
last one all right i don't know who this
is exactly but i guess he's some sort of
famous mountain biker
but check out this trick he did holy
[ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] hard pass for me oh
on rocks i wonder what kind of shock you
guys
yes how
that yes was a thank god he didn't die
yes that's just insane absolutely
saint george yes that's in utah i got so
many questions
question number one like how do you
practice that
well he probably does it on a ramp into
the soft and on the soft pit
but that's his ideal descent
i wonder what bike he was like the
shocks and not
my questions at all sorry yeah like this
is biker time what type of seat does he
is he had now is that a 38 fork um
what are we but he's also it looks like
he's a motorcyclist too right yeah
looks like he does all that stuff those
dudes are different
yeah it's just not especially the guys
that flip those bikes
[Music]
can you tell are you looking at the bike
yeah i can't tell
do you see how they have the downhill
shocks see how the shocks start at the
handlebars yeah see this one look look
at this
but jesus christ
here's another reason why these people
are they're a different breed
so he's not wearing any protection on
the upper half of his body
just the head so if he falls his
entire back and chest is gonna be one
giant open
wound see if it's almost like like these
guys like it's far f and few between who
make real money
so it's like you're trying to be this
guy or a ufc fighter like there's really
no
difference but the ufc guys have to make
more than these guys
but who like travis persona you know
what i'm saying like though some of
those guys like
some of those guys make real money dude
i'm just not
like extreme sports guys i i
i there's nothing in my dna when i see
that kind of stuff it makes me go
i gotta do it nothing in my dna
that looks like a yt bike it is what
does he ride one of the same bikes
that's a whitetail do you sleep naked or
do you no no no
i'm not a guy who's it's not that i'm
not comfortable i just don't i don't
know
how many dudes i'm comfortable naked but
it's not like i just i feel
if i see megan i feel like i lost
something i
i always feel like i'm missing something
like something's missing
i don't know why i can't really fear
that i'm gonna crush my nuts
i i don't i'm just not i just can't get
cozy naked
no you sleep naked cat yeah i can't
sleep with clothes on but they see
there's one or two people
yeah you either you're butt naked or but
i think
i'm not bundled with i mean i'm in my
undies i think women are more
comfortable sleeping
more i know more women who sleep butt
naked oh not me
you i don't know i'll do that sleeps
butt naked do you know a guy
it's just like it there's something
about the flop and i don't know a lot of
i don't know a lot of people in general
sleep naked you sleep butt naked cat
yeah
i can't i can take a nap for maybe an
hour with clothes on but if
it's anything longer than that i
naturally wake up i can't get
comfortable
even like like the winter kid yeah even
as a kid in the winter
in the winter are you from here yes oh
so you
might did you what's your my girl sleeps
in like a sweatsuit i'm like jesus
christ man
bro just sweat socks on like a hoodie
like
ugh do you not want to see my dick
what are you doing
beth wears panties in one of my t-shirts
every night that's sexy as [ __ ] it is
that'll do it it's so good my girl comes
in like the goddamn salt lake city
olympics
olympics every night she got bad
circulation like
this dictionaries not circulating
getting ready for the bobsled
ear muffs on july yeah
man getting jerked off with mittens
would be terrible no i don't want it
will you sleep and watch
in i have to have a shirt on too so i'll
show you shirt boxers and a real
comfortable shirt yeah actually what's
your girl sleep in
she'll actually naked that's why i
understand a lot of girls like to sleep
naked
naked
she sleeps naked naked buck naked this
is an
update to the bellathorn thing um now
that her only fan
is live she has made one million dollars
in 24 hours and within a week she made
two million dollars
she also says that she is not opposed to
posting
like kind of scantily clad photos of
herself
in her bra or like pictures of her butt
but her only fans
is just behind the scenes footage of her
in her day-to-day that's it
no nudes wow oh there's going to be
another she did it because someone was
going to
release her nudes she was like oh cool
story i'm starting no i think that's an
old
old story somebody threatened to release
her nudes and she released it herself
how many people tell me what percentage
of people as soon as she said i'm not
doing nudity just decided not to pay for
the second month oh my god god damn yeah
they were
yeah she still got two mil though yeah
but 85
of those dudes were like what like i
could
behind the scenes no she really
shouldn't have said that nah man i don't
want to see a makeup tutorial
teasing them man next next month you're
going to see a nipple hilarious
my son if there was a tease for a nipple
100
i mean whatever it's interesting that
the comedy central
they renewed tosh porno for four more
seasons and then they
took it back i wonder why you said
they're going towards the uh animation
stuff
and let me just say before anybody else
does i've been called
trailer park tosh crackhead tosh
old man tosh i get it i get it i get it
this dude his show
was so different when it first
and he delivered dark comedy and he
delivers it
in such with that boyish face that a
different not a dark delivery
like so it made it so much more
palatable the way he did it
i i think the way he he's a pioneer you
don't see like when he comes on stage
with that face
and the way he talks it's not jesus it's
so funny you you expect that out of
jesuit but when tash comes out you're
like i didn't expect
that out of his and he's it sounds like
they're taking the show to another
network though because he goes
this is his response he's actually funny
yeah he goes i look forward to doing an
animated
reboot on my show on mtv in 25 years he
goes uh after 12 years together coming
central i
are consciously uncoupling uh
they get cartoons and i'm head to any
network
[Laughter]
i mean there's some when you watch that
show
whether you never like him or not i
always watch that [ __ ] guaranteed
guarantee laughs